buenos dias alan es evidente que ahora
el país estará controlado como lo has
dicho por el gobierno socialista en la
oposición digamos encabezada por juan
guaidó no le queda más que reunificarse
porque y buscar espacios políticos ahora
que ya no hay unas más elecciones en
tiempos cercanos también tiene que
tratar de lograr una reconexión con los
seguidores que están totalmente
desconectados y están afligidos
digámoslo así porque el efecto cuando no
funcionó no pudo hacer ningún cambio en
el país el último año hoy comienza una
consulta popular que está promovida por
juan guaidó y 37 de sus partidos
políticos que lo apoyan y que no fueron
a estas elecciones para preguntarle a
los ciudadanos si decían de nuevo unas
elecciones presidenciales libres y si
quieren también
rechazar estos comicios que se
realizaron el día de ayer la idea es
entregar los resultados a la unión
europea ya estados unidos para que ellos
sigan presionando al gobierno de nicolás
maduro y lesbia le apliquen más
sanciones